مصابيح في الظلام في رحله ما قبل الفجر
داخل البركان الهواء كثيف بسبب الدخان
البركاني واقنعه تصبح ضروريه كلما اقتربنا
الى قلب
البركان يشكل الغاز مشهدا مدهشا لهب ازرق
يتموج كالاشباح فوق جدران
البركان في اسفل الفوه هذا ما
وجدناه عمال مناجم اندونيسيين يحفرون في
الكبريت الخام المتشكل قرب الفتحات في
البركان يبدو العمال وهم يجاهدون للتعامل
مع الغاز
البركاني
انا محظوظ لاني املك قناعا للغاز عامل
المناجم هذا يستخدم فقط قطعه قماش يضعها
في
فمه مع الفجر نجد اننا قرب بحيره على فوهه
البركان حمضيه للغايه
ودافئه حين يجمعون ما يكفي من الكبريت
يملا عمال المناجم سلال لهم ويبدون رحلتهم
الطويله المضنيه الى خارج
الفوها انها مسافه 800 متر سيرا على
الاقدام الى خارج الفوها معظمها صعودا على
منحدر حاد والعمال مثل سيد موستاد هنا
يحملون بين 85 و100 كيلوغرام من الكبريت
على ظهورهم ينقلون ما يوازي وزن رجل من
الكبريت صعودا على هذه الممرات الحاده
مقابل ما يساوي فقط حوالي 12 دولارا يوميا
وهو اجر رائع كما يقول نسبه لرجال كانوا
سيكونون لولا هذا العمل مزارعين فقراء هذا
يبدو واحدا من اشق الاعمال في العالم يبدو
ان هذا السوبرمان الحقيقي يوافق على
ذلك يستخدم الكبريت في النهايه لتصفيه
السكر وصناعه الصابون وعلاجات الجلد وحتى
في المواد المتفجره انه الحصاد الاصفر
للبراكين